Dubai already boasts the world's tallest building,...
...Burj Khalifa,...
...the biggest flower garden,...
...Miracle Gardens,...
...one of the world's largest aquariums;...
...yeah, America's got the title for that one!
Nope, China just beat it.
And now they plan on building the world's biggest mall,...
...and they'll call it, the Mall of the World.
They'll be stealing the title from themselves...
...as they already own the title with the massive Dubai Mall.
But let's put some things into perspective everybody.
The Mall of America in Minnesota is 4.87 million square feet.
The Dubai Mall is 12.1 million square feet,...
...but the Mall of the World will be a city-sized 48 million square feet,...
...and we literally mean city because it will be an indoor city.
The promenade will be seven kilometers long;...
...eight million square feet will be dedicated to shopping centers,...
...and it will be home to 100 hotels and apartment buildings with over 20,000 rooms.